my youtube is just per things
hi
show us the only fans duo
oh i'm just reading
videos so if you just google like mother
daughter only fans duo i'm sure you'll
find it
hi
what up
all right guys on my youtube live if any
of you have like a question for me or
like a topic you want to talk about go
to my instagram
and
join it because i haven't had anyone
join yet so if anyone joins
like
can talk about whatever
need you back on the fresh and fit i
know
am i in london no not yet
um
i fell off after i broke up with
angry reactions um
we're still
together i fell off after i didn't post
on tick tock for
like two months straight i would say
that's actually what did it
i was too focused on youtube like i was
having so much fun with it that i just
i fumbled a bag um
what about social engineering and all
the misunderstandings between men and
women
um
i don't know people are people to be
honest
like
people
i don't know but what does kevin samuel
say the world doesn't owe you
understanding
i think men like forget that women are
emotional creatures like i think
naturally like that's our inclination
is emotion so i feel like it's like the
guy's job to like lead with logic
especially in a relationship but
yeah the problem is we we get emotional
whatever you're doing you look great
thank you um i've actually fallen off
really bad with my diet the last two
weeks i've been traveling and
it just has not been going well
okay there's like more people on my ig
live
or my um youtube live
on my instagram live because i'm live on
two phones right now if you go over to
my instagram it's just pearly things but
with a z at the end
um
you'll be able to like talk to me and we
could like go over agreements or
disagreements
do i care
about my views on youtube yeah sure of
course i do
i get paid on views
okay requested someone who requested it
hi
yo what's up bry
i'm good how are you
i'll go okay there it goes hey um
i got my own opinions my own theories do
you think things in terms of the way
modern women are towards men do you
think anything's ever going to reverse
um
i think i have an unpopular opinion that
is based off of my intuition and not
data
so i wouldn't probably like shout this
off the rooftops or like die on it but
i actually think that
it will get a little bit better because
i think like over time people see the
consequences of like other people's
decisions and kind like each generation
is like a reaction to the previous
generation
um
so i don't know i could see people
going back
a little bit but
i don't know i haven't really thought
that through that much that's a good
question though what do you think
uh yeah there's um in fact there's a
term in psychology called bottoming out
um everything in life it don't matter
whether it's the weather whether it's
jobs no matter what it is everything
happens in cycles our bodies everything
happens reoccurring cycle and
there's a thing called bottoming out in
psychology where you get so low that you
can't do anything but get better you
know what i'm saying so maybe i think
that things are going to get better just
based off the law of physics in all of
life everything's a cycle well i think
people forget like the 70s happened you
know like i've heard i heard like stuff
was kind of crazy then too
what it was and um
like
like my generation was super like
liberal you know like super left
um and it came out of like left field
but the generation like my sister's
generation that's like 12 13 like
they're a lot more like conservative
which is like that's what i'm saying
like i feel like generations are kind of
a reaction where they go slightly the
opposite
because like my you know like my parents
generation is more like conservative and
i feel like it kind of like switches off
yeah
yeah i agree with that i think i think
generation generation each generation is
reaction to the previous yeah
yeah i definitely agree with that like
and i really appreciate you like making
these videos on youtube because i'll be
watching you it's like all your stuff
like it's rare that i could ever
disagree with what you say because
you're real logical so it's cool how you
can like even though going on fresh and
fit you ain't had the best experience
that second time it was it was crazy
because when i seen you on there i was
like
this is different than last night's like
she's scared to talk her like she's
nervous about like something happened
like it was weird like i know what
happened until you made that video but
like i i definitely i noticed i noticed
the big things well it was just like i
felt so awkward from like it was just so
like awkward that's like the best way i
know how to describe it
but it's funny because people were like
giving me like flag they're like oh you
betrayed them i'm like guys i don't know
them
at all
so i was like how do i betray someone
that i met twice
yeah but i think like i like the guys
that fresh and fit like the stuff they
say is true the only thing about it is
like the they're between them and i
watch them in kevin sanders the
difference between them and kevin
samuels
kevin samuels like
i think freshman pit myron and um
myron and fresh i think that they really
like
i think they really have some resentment
against women like
as a whole it's just very specific women
that they'll take a liking to
but i really i really think they got
some resentment just just you know the
stuff that's come out about them that's
true and like the story that you had and
everything
like
yeah um
i just
i don't know fresh and fit
like i think they're kind of like fake
it till you make it guys where like
kevin samuels
you can just tell he has like a crazy
like wealth of like knowledge you could
just tell like when he talks like he
knows way more than what he's talking
about does that make sense
resentment towards women um
i just think they're kind of in a bubble
like they don't represent normal people
that's like my biggest
like
what i wish i saw more on their show
because
like there's a lot of girls that have
never been asked to like flown out
somewhere in their lives and like don't
you know aren't really a part of the
fast life and just went to like small
colleges you know what i mean like
there's normal people out there but they
just only have girls that are like
super sexual like strippers only fans
models like i don't feel like it's an
even representation for like most
people yeah no that's true
everybody up there like they they really
are not the brightest like whatever that
phrase is they're not the brightest
females out the bunch
so you definitely write on that one now
fresh d do you think fresh gets as many
girls as he used to talk about he used
to get
um
no
um not i mean i don't know they
you know what they might only because
the girls they bring on are so trashy
you know like
and they're literally like bringing them
to an apartment
so
maybe i don't know
yeah cause i'm refreshed was talking
about how even before youtube and for
the money he said
he had he would have like four girls at
his apartment on a slow week every
single week and i'm like
like i'm not trying to be ugly but i
don't really see fresh
like i don't really see him
having girls like that without being
wealthy and having stats and popping
that's just i'm not saying that the
dude's ugly i don't think he's ugly i'm
just saying like i don't see him as one
of those types of guys
um
yeah i mean i don't either
four girls on a slow weekend
i could see him like doing okay
like before i i don't know
yeah
i could picture him doing decent i could
see him having like like you know
maybe a couple girls a month or
something just decent but you for like
that seemed a bit much and like nothing
about him screams that
yeah
no i wouldn't
i don't know i think that
a lot of like the games they play really
would only work on like gold diggers and
like kind of trashy girls
um
yeah because i just i grew up around
such different women because i grew up
in sports
um at like small colleges so it's just
such like a different experience you
know than like girls at like the big d1
schools
um like i was looking at like my most
attractive like female friends i would
say and all of them have under a
thousand followers like they're not
like out there like that
um so i think if they like tried to
approach some of like my friends like
that i just could not see it really
working you know
i feel the same way because i mean me me
myself i'm a christian and like i have
other christian friends and like what
they're talking
like that stuff
that stuff is good to look at if you
want to know how the world works and
what's going on but like
you gotta look at the caliber of people
that they're dealing with you know what
i'm saying
uh
a woman who has good virtues and values
is not gonna sit back and leave a dude
because he's making 35 cans she's making
45k i mean like really do you want to be
married to that type of person
like that girl who was on your show
yesterday the craziest thing i've ever
heard
about some 200 000 engagement ring
oh my gosh oh my gosh
she actually sent me um
like a a post today like double downing
on it where it like
like an example of some girl who got
that
um
i'm like you can want what you want it's
just like are you are you actually gonna
get it is that realistic
that's so unrealistic from her but men's
gonna spend 200 000 on an engagement
ring he's got to be at the minimum a
eight-figure millionaire you know
that girl was very much average
looking
i she probably was a dress size 10 the
way i looked at her face because she
seemed pretty round in the face
any man who hears that is going to run
in the opposite direction uh yeah these
these standards are absolutely insane
and that's the thing i heard somebody it
was you it was you talking about with
rich cooper i like him too you were
asking if men were hypergamous and the
answer is no it's just females that are
hypergamous like i say
hypergamy is not the issue the issue is
not hypergamy the issue we got going on
today is
this
it's hypergamy with a lack of
accountability and a lack of gratitude
you know what i'm saying
like it's just
all over the place well and the thing
that kind of baffled me a little bit was
i was like don't you want to ask me
questions about like what these guys
want like my brothers are these guys
like that
like
like my dad was that guy that could
afford that ring my older brothers are
those guys that could afford like you're
not asking me any questions about what
these guys want you're like telling me
what they want and the crazy thing is
like i know these guys and i know none
of them even with that amount of money
would ever spend that much money on a
rank
like ever my mom i asked her with the
most expensive piece of jewelry my dad
ever bought her and it was like in 100k
rank but like that was after 25 years of
marriage
so
what
yeah and eight figures or more
yeah
yeah
so
so no that was crazy actually i could
my mouth dropped i was like you said
what because i don't know anything about
rang so when she first said like the
ring i was like what does that mean and
then when she said 200k i was like
yeah but they really like i have i have
a friend and his his sister
she was telling me about the type of man
she we were all just sitting around
talking she was somehow
she wanted to be a millionaire
and
she was my husband's going to be at
midnight me and my husband will be
millionaires together and
she's she's like you she's five eleven
you're six people she's probably she's a
real tall person and while i was telling
to her i asked her like what does that
type of man want
and
she could barely even say what that guy
wanted and i told her
you do recognize
that most men who make the type of money
who are millionaires they're much older
not only that but most men are not that
tall so in order for you to get a man
he's got to be around your age
6-1 at least and he's also got to be a
millionaire like you you're gonna have
to settle for some stuff you know
because she's not one of those types of
people who she's the type of girl
that'll say
you know i can be submissive to the
right guy
that's like see and that never works
because it's so double-minded if i come
to you and say you know i can be
masculine and protect you what you mean
you can you are yeah you know what i'm
saying
and
that's the thing a lot of these females
nowadays i'm noticing are just talking
about what they want off the emotions
rather than actually looking at
themselves and accurately assessing
where they rank at you know what i mean
yeah and
the world actually lets women do
that
okay where are the plus-sized male
models you know what i'm saying we don't
get that type of privilege we have to be
very realistic with the we are very
realistic with ourselves and that's why
when you see a couple out you see
average looking dude kind of short you
see a woman who looks right about the
same way he does because men most men
pick realistically it's very rare that
you'll see
two people who just
one is
good looking and the other one is
downright ugly you know what's one thing
i learned like from watching manosphere
content which i was actually like
surprised by
um like i think as girls because like
we're somewhat naturally hypergamous
like we kind of assume like
guys are as well so like when guys date
another girl like we always like compare
ourselves to her like looks wise
i'd like and
it's funny because i did a poll because
i was just curious like asking guys if
they're like the x they missed the most
was like their best looking
ex said no
looks if she's nice
more than like
i think i really realize to be honest
yeah yeah men would do that men are not
like
like when men are real hype to bone
looks that's more when it comes to sex
like when it comes to a relationship men
will go down a couple of points in looks
if the girls real submissive
and real agreeable and whatnot because
like with a man like marriage is much
dangerous
from
and do preserve their value
um
every person you sleep with
makes it lowers your value um
your looks are your primary currency
and it is true
um
i'll tell you a story it's real life
story my cousin is the vp of a billion
dollar company
and he cheap on one of his wives and me
and my nana was talking about my nana
said she should have stayed with him i
was like well no she shouldn't have yeah
she should have not okay cool
and
so what happened is
in six months like kevin samuels
always it's just like kevin samuel says
my cousin gets married to another woman
who was i can easily say adjustable six
or seven
uh
two kids now
so it really is true um
that
a man who's at a higher value
it doesn't mean he's more likely she
well yet actually it does
um
man is when men have more options most
men
do
not have
the level of
moral i don't know what to call it but
most men
if you give them the op
[ __ ]
do it
um
his wife that he has now even though i
think the whole cheating thing was wrong
like i don't think men should sleep with
women just because they can
but it definitely is true that if you if
you're going to date a guy who has a lot
more options you do run a bigger risk of
cheating because
men
really like there's a reason why men
watch for porn oh no i definitely think
like as i said on the show like i think
characters rare and like people
who do the right thing when no one's
watching like that's rare
and i think it's like you kind of have
to acknowledge that really any um
capable of it and that's why it's like
important not to like put yourself in
certain situations you know
um
yeah but
like i definitely think it's more likely
if people have money
what i don't appreciate like about the
red pill is just like they act like
character is non-existent
and it doesn't exist um and that's like
where like if i had to guess out of like
high value men what percent chi i'd
probably guess like between 50 to 75
like i'd say like one in four probably
don't if i had to guess um
but it kind of
goes back to what i was saying on the
show is like i think there's two types
of rich people there's the type of rich
people that like
live the fast life and like go to the
bars go to like all the nice events all
that stuff and then there's the rich
people that like get their money and go
live on a piece of land and don't deal
with people
and i just happen to know like more of
the latter
most rich people that i know
you don't know they're rich ever or if
you do
it because
they maybe loved cars or it's after they
made all the money they wanted to get a
real nice house but you you really don't
know people who actually have money so
like what you what you said was
following their um and you got questions
for me about how men think about women
and whatnot how men um how old are you
you're 23.
okay sorry i'm just thinking like based
on your age um are you still in school
wait say wait a second everything start
breaking up go again yeah i think
i think it's your wi-fi i'm not gonna
lie to you you've been kind of breaking
up the whole time a little bit
um
23 year in school
do you think
that
do you think that young people want to
get married like guys under the age of
28
like do you think like do you have any
friends that actually want to get
married young
yeah like all my friends want to get
married all my friends either do get
married young or they or they want to
get married young oh interesting okay
most of my friends most people closest
to me are are other christians so they
want to get married young but um
most men
have the mentality of i'm just out here
trying to do my thing and if the right
woman comes by then i'm definitely going
to take that that's what that's attitude
most young men have
[Music]
yeah um
do you think that
most guys marry the girl that like they
loved the most or the girl that was
there at the right time
most men
marry the girl that was there at the
right time
because people make marriage decisions
off of their feelings and whoever is
with them in that time that they feel
like they need the most
that's who they stick with
yeah that's what i always felt like too
like i feel like
it almost females too like it's kind of
just who's there when they're like ready
to get married sometimes
from what i've like seen
i was just curious if you thought it was
the same for men because they're like
more in
control of like the ring you know
someone said in the chat i'm live on two
audiences
um a 23 year old can't guys anyone on my
youtube live go to my instagram live um
that's where you can like request to
like be in it or ask questions
um
okay
let's see
it's interesting the church is a little
like different like in terms of like a
social circle
um
because i've seen that too like in the
church people get married a lot younger
yeah and i'll be real with you pearl
dayton in okay
because like for like this is like
like serious and people don't notice
unless you're in it
the higher up you go with christianity
as a man you got to be more careful
because
here's how things work there are local
colleges that i'll go to
to do work at um
wait a second
mail talking to everybody the same way
won't try to hit on nobody or nothing
one thing i noticed on that campus is
that there was never men and women by
themselves and i was like that's weird
and so me i was having regular
conversations and you know the females
we'll talk like 45 minutes meeting god
talk 45 minutes and they'll engage back
and forth with me asking me deep
questions and everything
one of the managers that knew me came
and said hey david man some people have
been reporting that you're making them
feel uncomfortable i was like oh yeah
what i do is like just talking to them
while they're alone
and that happened to me over at um uncg
which is the college i went to
and so
i'm over here and i'm telling my boys
like dude like i'm literally not doing
nothing and this is the second time that
i've had females go off and tell
somebody about me when i'm literally not
even attracted to the ones i'm i'm not
even trying to flirt
you know what i'm saying and there was
something like dude that happened to us
too
and the only it's like
these girls here are so prudent to the
point where it's just not normal and he
says like the only way that you can
really talk to a female here is if it's
in a big friend group and if a
relationship happens like it could
happen but like
for some reason the more christian that
a lot of females become the more
this isn't good hypersensitive they are
to every little thing that happens and i
wanted to mention that note
when those girls reported me to the
manager who was happy he knew me me and
him were cool when those girls reported
me to the manager i'll bet you the one
thing they didn't say is that we was
talking it wasn't no one excited
conversation
they had the right they could have stood
up and left it any moment they could
have said something at any moment you
know what i mean they kind of said i
gotta go
where are you
there they engaged
and asked me all these questions and
whatnot and i'm sitting there like
they didn't say that part what part of
this
what part of the country are you in that
it's like this
north carolina oh okay so down south
okay i could see that
and the thing like
and that's why me
hadn't even done nothing to nobody i
have a thing like i told my dude friends
man hey look when it comes to a certain
type of christian girl
um i don't if she don't talk to me i
don't talk to her
and like that ties into that similar
thing to
chivalry is dead and women killed it
because you would rather report somebody
who wasn't even doing nothing
you would you would rather report
somebody
than to just simply sit back and say
hey look i've got to go somewhere we're
just or just get up and say hey look i
don't want to talk i'll be comfortable
but you you won't go and report and that
could have done anything to my name you
know what i'm saying so
that's that's um that's why people say
shield is dead women killed i i
resonated with it perfectly
no that's that's crazy like you're just
having a normal conversation and they
reported that's so weird
normal and this is and i told my friends
i was like yo
i legitimately were like yeah i
understand like we both had experiences
like that and i was males and females
i don't see males of females together
and see and that's the thing
that ties to menosphere
a lot of these relationship issues
i'm just saying
it's not us
we're not bringing complexity
and
and you know this new age crap we're not
doing it
it's the it's the women
who create this mess and start this
stuff see men
but you have to who who owns the media
outlets
who passed
yeah who passes the laws
mostly
especially like historians yeah so like
men enable it
and men like men men like like write off
like the money that comes with it that's
the problem men can be bought
[Music]
we do in it yeah i will say yeah we do
on on our end we do enable this behavior
because look the dude who was um the
guru who reported to me he didn't he
could have told them hey look well did
you did you were you continuously
talking to him or how did the
conversation go why did you not get up
and leave see that's i like that you
said that because us men
the women may have started it but on our
part like we're not we we are not
causing it
but we need to be holding women
accountable yeah
that's what i'm saying like men in
society and i'm not like saying this
from like a like a feminism perspective
like women should have the power but
like men do hold more positions of power
in general like men run society more
than women
um
and that's fine but like at the end of
the day like they're more in control
women they just like they just see if
they see they can make money off of it
they just ride it
and
so it's unfortunate
and that's the thing like i say it's
women's fault but it's our
responsibility to hold women accountable
as far as we can
yes
i think the church has really bad dating
advice actually i think dating is
actually terrible in the church
why do you say that um
like
i just think there's a lot of like
nonsense especially like the church i go
to um
it's called it's it's a church of christ
but it's not like the it's not the weird
one that doesn't have music like i it's
everyone always thinks it's that one but
it's not
um but they would just like
like there's this one guy
that was like literally waiting for this
girl for years
and like it's like they need to get
everyone involved in like this
relationship that like get advice from
like the higher ups about who they
should date all this stuff i'm like why
don't you just tell her you like her and
see what happens
like
i don't know it just like yeah
especially in christians i've been like
in christian and catholic churches i
think like catholics are a little bit
like less nonsensey like in christian
churches
like
everyone just needs to be involved
and like it's just so much more like
gossipy and i don't think it's helpful
towards relationships and
they like they tell like they take
forever they're just like oh let god i'm
like that's not gonna
like when you can't date outside of the
church but it's 75 women like
oh shoot where'd he go
oh my gosh guys if you're gonna be rude
in the chat
okay i think someone else anyone else
request
okay i lost this guy i think i'm gonna
take the next person
um
oh my gosh
hi
hi
what's up i'm good how are you
you guys were talking about um dating
within the church so i i actually was
going to ask you the christianity
allowed dating
because i'm less fun
okay we're actually not allowed to date
what do you do
i know it's weird right like when you
you're gonna be marrying this person and
then you can't even date them no
it's more like a vetting process
i guess
um
so the way my husband asked me to get
married was um
i guess people just knew him in the
community and then and talked to my dad
and
um
um
yeah he came and talked to my dad and
then we got to know each other um so i
guess you would consider that baby i
mean you just
they put me for a
shorter amount of time
i actually prefer that it's like almost
it's like
sorry go ahead
i said um sorry i think i broke up a
little bit but i was saying that um
we did bake for like five okay like five
weeks
um
and then we kind of decided okay let's
kind of decide like if this person's
good for me it's gonna be a good father
good husband and
um so how long did you know him before
i knew him like i was i'm very involved
in my mom
so i would do a lot of the youth
activities and he would as well
um and he was more of like a mentor for
the boys so i i knew of him but i never
i was never friends with him he never
hung out or anything like that
so
i mean i knew him i would say like
probably a year and a half
oh wow and so then your dad had to like
vet him first
so he actually asked about me because he
had like
got in touch with my dad and had asked
if he could get to know me and
um
and my dad was like hell no my dad
wanted to like he was so upset
because you would think like middle
eastern dance they like want to get
their daughters married but it's a
complete opposite my dad wanted to shoot
someone he was he was ready to like come
with his gun
but um
so it took him time to like convince my
dad to let me get to know him
um so
you know
when you speak of marriage i could
understand why people would be afraid of
it you know the commitment
well
i actually like don't really mind like
super intentional dating and i actually
think it's like
it's not practical i think for most
people like i don't think most people
are going to do it but i think it's
really good to have your dad like vet
guys
you know because he's good
yeah i think it's a good thing to be
honest i always say like i would be
totally okay with an arranged marriage
i've always said that
my problem with like christian churches
is i just feel like it's so slow and
they don't tell girls to like
get moving
especially the church i'm in like girls
will be like 30 35 and they're not even
like they're like oh god's timing's
always right and i'm when i'm like
when i'm like maybe you should like take
some steps to like speed in a lot
be like interactive don't just sit there
and wait for god to throw blessings yeah
right and that's my problem with
christian like
what i've seen of christian dating is
like
like one it's not even the family that
gets involved it's like the mentors of
the church which i think it should be
more your family and then on top of that
like it's like
just let god's timing it'll happen when
i'm i'm more of like someone that's like
you know if i have a goal like i want to
take steps towards that goal and that
just
and then they don't even and they don't
want you to date out of the church but
there's three women to every one guy
so it's like
that's crazy
so when you go to church do they
actually try to like encourage the youth
to get married they do they
they have like singles conferences that
you can go to yeah yeah so like they
definitely encourage people to get
married i just
i i'm just
like they don't provide the proper
resources
right
like premarital counselling
yeah do they offer that um i don't know
i've never been married i like um i
think they do
um
like i don't i think they have some good
ideas but the other thing i don't think
the church addresses like is if a if
you're a girl right and you have a kid
outside of marriage
what what are the odds that the next guy
is gonna like wait
like
and like the church is like oh just
you know all like trust god that's what
our moth says too like they they sweep
all these
it seems like
it's like all their religions like
if there's issues like they don't we
don't talk about depression we don't
talk about anxiety
we sleep it under the rug
because god forbid if you are a godly
person then why would you have
depression you know what i mean
just all these issues with like marriage
and mental health and all this stuff i
feel like it's swept under the rug
so
how long have you been married for oh my
god i've been married for 15 years wait
how you look so young i was like thought
you were like i thought you were like
i'm 30 i'm 32. oh wow okay i was
thinking you're like 25-ish
oh thanks
thank you i was like 15 years wait so
how old were you when you got married
you're pretty young that oh my god yeah
i was 19. i was not even thinking about
getting married are you quiet are you
glad you did it that young
yes
i am because i watch a lot of the red
pill stuff right some of it is lunatic
crazy and i like actually like your
channel i like how you review um
you know freshens this
concepts and things like that
and i'm actually glad i got married
young because i see how difficult it is
um for girls to get married
i don't know or maybe find like a good
potential person
well i think no well i think a lot of
times like
you're not really told about one like
age gap dating where if you want to get
married young like
you're probably not going to find a guy
your age that's going to want to do that
um and then you're also not like i think
a lot of girls go to college you know
and just make
like different decisions um
which
you know there's like pros and cons to
that but
yeah i don't know when i don't think
college really promotes like marriage
it doesn't i don't think it does no no
because a lot of it like why is it so
difficult oh i want to get my education
or i want to get married you can do both
yeah one doesn't take away from the
other
you know my husband still like yells at
me he's like go get because i haven't
finished my degree i have three kids i
was going to school and then we got
pregnant and
um
i decided to like stay at home with my
kids but that was never my plan
i always thought i was going to be like
have a career go to school finish school
and then get married but i'm so glad
that
it happened the way it is
how old is your youngest
oh my god my youngest is two okay are
you done or you want more
i want more i want like a village
yeah i want like five kids the reason i
say that is because my oldest son has
autism and
i want him to have a lot of siblings
around him and a lot of hopefully
nephews and nieces you know what i mean
i just want a big family for him
yeah no i love having a big family i
think it's a shame so many people stop
after two
i know my typical american family like
two kids and
i love my siblings but i can't say that
too loud or my brother will hear him
oh i have nine
one brother oh no i have nine
nine yeah
that's amazing do you want to have a big
family like that
probably not that big um i think my
not 10 um
i think
i think my ideal would be
four maybe or five probably um
but it's gonna depend obviously on like
my husband and what we can afford you
know um i try not to because i feel like
at the end of the day it's kind of like
the husband's choice on some end because
like especially if they're the one
providing for it exactly they're
expensive yeah
very expensive
um one more question and then i'll let
you go um
i was gonna ask you about
um
are you going to be continue to do fresh
and fit
content or are you going to just
are you going to expand
um
i'm i think i've been looking at more
retail topics like
um
the next couple months um well i'm
probably it's kind of gonna slow down
until i move to england but i'd really
like to do more interviews
yeah i'm moving in like a week maybe two
depending on my visa
yeah
wow that's so cool
um
yeah but
when
but i probably want to do interviews
mostly like coming up and then like
maybe more man on the street like i
think i'm going to do more original
content than like reactions like maybe
like a show where like
girls can call in or something and guys
like whatever um
but yeah that's i just haven't had time
to like set everything up because i'm
moving so after i move it's going to be
like more consistent
are you moving for school or work or
just um i'm gonna play overseas so i'm
gonna play volleyball
that's amazing yeah yeah i'm pumped wow
i need to play volleyball how tall are
you
that's
wow
yeah
i love meeting tall girl
where are you at where are you located
l.a okay cool
if you ever want to come out to l.a let
me know yeah enough i seriously like if
you told me that back in may i was there
for like a month i was so bored like i
can't i just found you
like i literally did not know anyone i
met up with like a bunch of people i
like met online
okay well let me know next time you come
to l.a okay okay totally well it was so
nice
yeah nice talking to you too
all right i'll see you take care bye
okay
she was so nice
it's like funny okay the funny thing is
when i meet like especially my female
followers
like it's kind of crazy how it's like
you are what you attract because i
always can like
have weirdly like stuff in common with
um
like
i don't know it's just kind of funny how
it's like
random people on the internet you like
find
you're like oh
um okay
sorry guys i know i don't look at the
left at the youtube chat when i'm on
like live with someone i try to like
watch
both
yeah nice talking to you too
um
oh gosh okay um yeah if anyone wants to
request for like the next one
i'm gonna read some of the questions
from my chat on the left
um
like the internet is so cool it is so
cool that you can just at the touch of
the button like literally talk to anyone
anywhere
okay guys stop saying it looks stoned i
do not look stoned
it's just my face i get that all the
time
um
let's see anyone on the chat from
youtube feel free to go to my instagram
and you can like
request me there
what function does religion even serve i
don't know i think people like
do better when they're like
serving a higher purpose i think it like
motivates people not everyone you know
um okay
okay i found you by sarah sarah garvey
you're welcome to britain plus you have
a fan base here so we look forward to
seeing you maybe you'll do live events i
probably will do live events
i'm so excited for when i can actually
get into a group with this stuff like i
love youtube i literally love what i do
um
am i getting married i hope someday
i'm a little bit different in the mana
sphere where
i think it's like better to get married
younger as a girl but like i don't ever
think you should like get married out of
a place of like fear
and sometimes i think like the
manosphere pushes like fear on women
like you're just getting older it's
going to be over for you
but like realistically
like
you can
you really only need like six months if
you really want to get married
um
uh okay we're gonna
remove this guy from the channel
oh wait can i block him
okay guys just you know in the chat
um
i block people that are rude um nothing
personal it's just like kind of
distracting when i'm going through and
it's like not productive conversation
how many dms do you get daily by simps
um no it's not crazy like people think
you get like
hundreds of dms maybe like one to two a
day
i don't my instagram really isn't that
big
um
what happened oh shoot
what happened oh it's my chat on the
left is my youtube chat
pearly come to
croatian next year
maybe i'm traveling
okay i watched the women demands 200k
engagement ring why do a lot of girls
like your friend always assume the topic
was men attacking only fans girls
why do they think men want to control
women the sisterhood is so strong like
does she also no that girl doesn't do
only fans
i think girls especially like when you
first watch the red pill you kind of
feel like
attacked a little bit because like
it's just like no matter what you do
like the red pill just has
something they're gonna complain about
right like
someone said that they shouldn't like
you shouldn't date an extroverted girl
because then she's gonna be [ __ ] and
it's like
like so now if i'm extroverted i'm not
what like and sometimes
it just gets kind of exacerbate like
exhausting just listening to how bad
women are all day because that's not
what i see in my real life like
as i've said like some of my most
attractive friends have less than a
thousand followers they're not getting
flown out by these guys
um
but
i don't know if that makes sense but
yeah i think that's why she was like
my chat on the right it says it has two
minutes left so
it'll end but i'll just restart it like
okay um
okay
the
do you think that more you should
advocate for more girls to get into
sports i think it prevents girls from
becoming 304s
yes
a hundred percent
like i mean i do think like maybe at
like big d1 schools
like it's a double-edged sword like in
college when you play a sport you're
definitely like more sought after as a
girl
um especially like the big schools like
small schools it's not as bad but
i do think like you don't make as many
bad decisions because you're so busy
like all the time
um okay
de sao the zo i'm going to accept your
live but it gives me an hour limit on
instagram so it's about to end
um and then i'm going to restart it so
i'm going to end the live really quick
but then i'm going to restart it if you
request the next live
i'm going to add you
okay i've restarted the other live do
you think more blue collared guys should
make an extra effort to
progress financially for modern women i
don't really understand the question
um
to progress financially
i think blue collar guys tend to make
more money than people really give them
credit for
so i'm not really sure the correct
question
i wonder why it has an hour limit on
instagram
okay
adam i can't see your message when i'm
live
hey hey
hi hello i'm sebastian
hi nice to meet you
yes okay uh
yeah let me tell let me tell you like a
lot of a lot of guys you know
a lot of guy doesn't understand
like the
doesn't understand the blueprints and
the red pills they don't understand that
a lot of a lot of guys are really
immature about that they really don't
understand they're broken in their web
page it's not you you human do you know
no i hear you i'm just listening yeah
yeah the blue pill and they were in
their parents they're not free to
like to push women or to hate women
it's like broken you need ah we watch
since they send the trailer markets i
will raise the market i watch everything
and
understand the grouping and the workers
so high level the propelling the red
bill is not free to hate women it's just
the truth
like even men have the blueprints even
me like we have the bruising the weapons
i can't stay all day sleep doing nothing
not working on myself like i need to
know i need to work hard to make money
i'm a man you know
people that's bashing women that's
that's kind of bad that sounds bad but
hey he's not really for that
well um
i don't necessarily like
like i think if you're gonna bash
certain women for making poor choices
like i don't see a problem with that
my my i guess like issue with the like
red pill is
they don't often represent like reality
um they make it seem like the brittany
runners and like the 304s from miami are
just like all women
um and like that's the majority when
like like i'm gonna be honest i've
literally never met a girl that's been
flown out anywhere like
i've tried to find like i've texted like
a bunch of girls i played sports with
whatever
i can't find one
um i'm not saying they don't exist or
maybe they don't tell me i don't know
but like
i feel like they don't really like give
credit to the more like normal people of
the world come on no
yeah like the like
like people that don't live these like
crazy extravagant lives it's live yeah i
can't understand you but like
deeply okay
okay does those two or four girls they
they show that they like the really
nasty side of the woman right
it's bad and they
they would destroy it and
and they talk about it in this city or
that but
this is still the woman nature you know
even though women women don't show it in
the internet even though you you're not
showing your the nature you're not
saying like what you're doing because
it's personal of you you know you can't
show it with your boyfriend or your
husband don't understand
still you is still the woman nature
that's why it's bad because the way they
acted and the social media you know the
way they do it for free the way you do
it for
what do you mean
what do you mean by like the female
nature like i think you'd have to like
define like what actions
okay yeah female nature
is hypergamy like women will always will
always love someone a guy that's
dominate when will even though she is
not showing she will she will always
love it and the bad and every single way
even though she is not showing it even
though she is not up to it even though
she is more masculine even though she is
making more money you want the guy to be
more dominant
but more serious like
right i think i think
yeah i think women are attracted to like
leadership qualities
yeah
[Music]
and there's like but there's like a
positive and like a negative side to
leadership
and that's what i'm saying like they're
attracted to like like you know the good
leaders like the ceos presidents
whatever but they're also attracted to
like the you know felons
like
i think i'm gonna start a youtube
channel or stuff like that i got so much
idea that i can i can open so much video
that i can make
that can be way better to explain in a
woman and that can like you can find
yourself into it more because i see the
way you talking you you enter the
webpage in the blueprints but you don't
you say oh they got nice women too yes i
know they got nice women but all those
women you're more outside them all the
bars women go motion themselves than the
good woman like
they made the hurts bro wait wait say
that again
wait say that again like if you have
like
do you hear me yeah no i'm listening i
just i couldn't hear what you said yeah
yeah it's like it's like if you have
like ten percent of good woman it's like
you got like seven people said like you
know the position of bad woman is so big
like the way the woman acts nowadays
it's so big it's like you can't not see
the good woman that's why he's so
rational well i mean i think the problem
is like
social media right like in the same way
like girls have these crazy high
standards like what gets clicks in the
red pill
like women does this
yeah and so like clearly if you're like
watching that constantly like you're
gonna think that's reality
you know
okay
like like that's that's what i'm saying
and that's that's why i asked like like
when i asked like different content
creators i say what percentage of women
like do you think are marriageable or
like what percent of women do you think
are like this and it's a really
important question ninety percent of
women is airsmith is it ten percent of
like that's there's such a big variance
right and when i was on fresh and fit
they tell me they think 95 of women are
not marriageable today 95. like
that's what i'm saying and so like then
it begs the question
is it is it women or is it the women
they choose to hang hang around right
hang on right is it yeah like some men
don't know how to choose
right
like
if you watch kevin samuels i've never
asked him that question right like i've
never i mean i've had i was on a show
once but it was like for like five
seconds
um
yeah
um but like i doubt it would be that
high because he doesn't have that like
disdain you know almost towards women
that's like
like he thinks they're so bad like you
know what i mean because the women he
surrounds himself by he speaks so highly
of right
like so badly
no i think he recognizes like i i'd have
to ask him the question i don't know
but if you listen to him talk about the
women like he surrounds himself with he
talks very highly like he definitely
thinks that women are bad right like you
see them on a show
i don't i don't disagree that they exist
but like there's a difference between
like like 95 percent of women and like
50 percent
like does that make sense
since okay okay
i guess
because you try to say it's like they're
also good women too
no i'm saying
right i'm
i'm saying that like
people people become so
enamored in the red pill they start to
think it's like 95 percent of women
that's what like when they get too deep
and i would argue
and i wouldn't say like oh there's some
good women too i would say there's a lot
of good women like i wouldn't say it's
just like five percent of women i would
say it's like
30 to 40 from like my experience
oh no i think it's higher than that
right and still even though the woman is
not bad it's not bad like as hard
like the other ones
but it's still the woman nature
it's not like they're talking bad about
women it's still the woman nature
oh my gosh so i mean women literally is
not bad what you
they have to explain it to me
to understand it like okay let me
explain to you let me explain to you
what i'm trying to say
adam i'm on a lie i don't hit it i'm
destined and i'm not like i'm not
assuming what i'm gonna do hold on when
i was now say okay what's my friendship
okay i'm not gonna it's okay
i'm gonna be her if she's cheating
if she's sitting i know she's gonna
cheat it i know it's gonna treat me okay
don't think it's not like you
it's not like a
it's a woman like i don't know i don't
know how to explain it to you but
it's not like all a woman or bad
mm-hmm it's like human nature it's not
like that what
well i think like human nature like
again i've always said i think character
is rare i don't think like people doing
the right
i lost them
um i well in like 10 minutes
there's no
okay sorry you're back
yeah like the thing the thing is like
it's hard like
like me personally i i don't i don't
hate women mm-hmm
because my concept of my idea like
you're way better than a lot of people
they don't understand the concept of
opening records yeah you had a lot of
men they got like like like do what did
you watch the album preach video they
say like
men have to take
their weapons you watch that video that
they did i don't know if you watch it
they say men and men how to take like i
i started a day of my life or something
like that i had to take the red piece
it's like you have to take it because
you have to understand women because the
further understanding women is like you
you're being broken it's your whole life
you can't find a woman that
use you like
take your own money yeah woman like over
30 years old that's gonna buy you for
your money like after like giving you
like you need to understand if you don't
understand that life you're gonna lose
right no no i i 100 like i think i think
like i think character is rare like
across the board men women like i think
people that do the right thing when
there's no consequences which for women
they've taken away a lot of the
consequences legally right
um
and people that do the right thing when
no one's watching i think that's rare
so like like but i i see that in like
men and women like people like i think
people that can get away with stuff like
a lot of times do
um but like i think a lot of times like
instead of it becoming like productive
like a lot of times guys just say oh
screw marriage like
and kind of go into relationships like
scared
and i don't think that's like a healthy
way to go into relationships
because nothing worth having
like everything worth having comes with
risk
okay okay okay
let me tell you
because
okay a lot of guys in america are [ __ ]
in america a lot of guys make them
that's what happening a lot of guys i
don't know i don't feel america uh i
came with you like four years ago you
know a lot of guys in america they don't
understand like me i didn't know the
word place in the group is but i had it
i had it in my head it's like i knew
like hey i don't trust women
you know if you if you know it's not
like it's not like nobody's
you can you cannot find someone that's
not gonna cheat on you it's like that
but you don't show us like you don't
believe in everything like you don't
believe in fairy tale
you can find someone that's not doing it
to you but hey you just don't believe it
oh right i mean the percentage is is not
that high you know you don't believe it
because others if you sit on you're
gonna say okay it's too cheap you know
and you didn't you need to learn also
like why [ __ ] she did why you didn't
give it to her like what was the mistake
i was wrong like was like everything
everything's like is important in the
relationship like
okay when [ __ ] like i heard a guy i said
i watched your video on youtube the guy
said hey i'm married twice and all of
them like cheat on me like what happened
what is the problem why is the problem
with you man like did you really good
and bad or
or like you you wasn't men enough like
he was nasty enough like you would you
didn't lead her good like
what what
what she's missing what both of those
women missing and knew that people
cheated or you know he doesn't like like
or he doesn't have like pick women well
right like yeah
yeah
i mean like you don't think you don't
think
what's his face like pj or whatever you
don't think he like the guy that you
know had a kid with britney runner you
don't think he had the option to like
find a good girl like with all the girls
in his dms
he's like
he's bad that's what i'm saying like
like there are guys that like have the
option to like pick a girl that's like
there for the right reasons like you
can't you cannot say that man could not
find one girl
that guy
is hurtful as a man he hurts yeah
he hurt me back but
i still
don't listen ah [ __ ] it
you know because he's like he's looking
for it he's like something he'll look
looks like right well
right i mean people are flawed that's
the thing like people want to say like
women are flawed like
men are flawed too like people in
general are flawed
that's why that's why the idea of
popular weapons is not here to hurt
women yeah a lot of men doesn't get it
it's like to understand women and to
acknowledge it and to understand yeah
and to choose the best one or maybe to
do your life though you decided to marry
your mind yeah you get it because
him
the guy meet the girls the girls putting
it out around her name she's fun as hell
mm-hmm she's a devil but she's fine you
know
hey i'm a player i got money you should
know my life's already on the center
you're not going from right that girl
you just put like three condoms in your
tank you know and yeah
and
kick her like for six months i don't
know when you get tired just give up you
understand you already know her
you're not going here too married like
with no condoms you can get sick like
you said the guy losing his
yo me i got my girlfriend i've been your
friend for six months i don't know for
even one year
i don't care
because i don't want to have kids i'm
too young i want to enjoy my life
i don't know i still don't know her you
know
people they don't understand a lot of
guys you're losing your life like that
is stupid you know that's why
that's that's why you need to
that's why he's a better easy right
right
i mean i don't i don't like hate the red
pal i think it's like definitely a
reaction to feminism like i think
there's so much like man-hating stuff
that like it's just a reaction
um but i'm just someone who kind of
meets somewhere in the middle you know
well uh
i get i gotta understand but you you
shouldn't even be in the middle you
should be in there and they're like
weapons because like then let me explain
it to you
okay you can be in the mirror because of
a lot of majority of men some of men
don't understand the way prison group is
real good
the well-presented group is nothing to
hate women or to hate women it's just to
understand it and acknowledge it and
let you choose better right you yeah
make sure no okay i'm a man i have to
leave i have i have i have to know how
to talk and i need to i need to take off
myself i need to choose the best woman i
need to you know protect myself my
family like everything it's not like
he's okay i hate that girl oh she did
that to me she did bad to me
you wanna do you you still get it
because a lot of men some men they don't
have those problems in their life some
men they are married with women and if
they keep they keep their girls here
next year next to that's next next to
him and the girls can't do nothing
because
like the way his family as you can hear
him is already
in his life already understand some
people the way the family educate them
is what pills
like without even know his weapons yeah
don't get it do get it yeah because you
know how to treat women you know how to
control a girl he's not okay that girl
is i know
what you're doing hey you know don't do
that to me see a lot of a lot of guys
also groupies in america i understand
men go on the internet and crying and
video
what the hell is that i know you should
cry as a man like me i cry i'm not gonna
lie i cry but let's come in the internet
and cry
when i'm crying it's like me i'm
thinking i say hey okay
what happened when something you hurt
you you need to cry i don't tell you as
a man you're not gonna cry like being
robot but not over the internet like the
way you crying like yo it's ugly man you
you mean you need to understand and
control yourself as a man like it's a
lot of things i i don't know how to
explain it to you but is so much
different than that and
and wasn't because
a lot of men like when when they are
devosted like everything they're not
they are taking
care of themselves like they don't go to
the gym they don't build themselves
again it's like they lose everything
like some people some men they get it
and they say okay i'm gonna handle
myself better i'm gonna i'm gonna choose
better like i'm gonna beat my life you
know maybe i can find other girls but
i'm not gonna write but hey a lot of men
get it but a lot of men they still
devote it they say okay why did you want
that marriage why she left me asking
they don't acknowledge the problem like
how to be better man
and and for that problem
does that happen anything you know yeah
no yeah i don't know if you get it but
yeah you're talking for a while so
i'm sorry
it was nice to meet you
yeah because i've been seeing you on
youtube you see
you try you try to get the red version
of the progress you never get it because
that's why i was trying to call you to
make sure you understand he's not like
you know yeah
what was it okay thank you it's nice to
meet you
okay me too thank you okay bye
he was just talking about a lot of stuff
he lost me i'm not even alive okay i'm
gonna
i'm gonna end this train because my
brother wants to go to bed
um
okay
guys i will talk to you guys
later
thanks for watching